bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo
tornati su alto adige ragazzi che mi
sembra stranissimo che dopo tutto sto
casino stiamo per uscire c'è siamo
arrivati all'uscita non so come e vabbè
dai usciamo che cazzo che aspettate la
più che metto la attrezzatura da
splinter cell perché sono qua non vedo
una mazza di niente vi giuro è più c'è
più luce dentro che fuori una cosa
impressionante buon giorno è che bella
giornata è bella per portare fuori il
cane sempre chi è questo sia un cane
comunque non la disturbo stia tranquillo
alla ragazzi dobbiamo andare da qualche
parte non so dove cioè io vedo due luci
in croce cioè io seguo le luci perché
non so dove andare alla tipo questa
ragazzi dove dove cazzo stati serve una
chiave per aprire la porta a ragazzi
devo prendere una chiave ok fermi che ci
sono
ragazzi c'è vi giuro è passato un ufo un
qualcosa del genere non so cosa ho
trovato qualcos'altro ragazzi non so che
cosa sono cos'è una catapecchia
ho trovato una capanna dispersa nel
giardino nessuno e uccidermi bene così a
perfetto la chiave per grandi è la
chiave per accedere al capanno della
manutenzione perfetto e allora ci siamo
c'è anche una batteria che non posso
prendere perché ho le batterie piene
ragazzi che che cos'è sta roba
cioè non c'era prima questo non c'era
terra prima c'era o non l'ho visto non
lo so vi giuro non c'erano è possibile
ci sono cose marchio presto giardino è
meglio che me ne vada il prima possibile
perché sennò c'è finisco malissimo
perfetto dare sam entrati via così
chiudi la porta che vi girano ne voglio
più sapere piuttosto preferisco star
dentro comunque ragazzi casi sono due o
troviamo l'uscita seria o vi giuro che a
sto punto è meglio star tirar dentro che
fuori lontana team che
c'è chi sa sono arrivato addosso ma
[ __ ] che chi era quel cos'è
successo
non sono neanche morto tutto erano no
non ho capito una mazza di quello che è
successo non va bene così e se qualcuno
avesse per caso qualche spiegazione sono
tutte ben accette mio zio santissimo non
so se sotto la scrivania qualcosa o
distrutto perché non è possibile allora
ragazzi stiamo salendo sul tetto come
sempre ci improvvisiamo ezio auditore
dobbiamo andar via di qua prima che devo
buttarmi a sopra penso allora forse devo
no aspettate che qua c'è qualcosa
perfetto mio dio
le mie doti da parkour ragazzi c'è
un'apertura da sopra gun dobbiamo
rientrare nel manicomio quanto sono
contento ragazzi è devo entrare qui
dentro purtroppo ancora non ho capito
sto cercando di spiegarmi che cazzo era
quella roba di prima anche se non lo so
ha dato una legata pazzesca non importa
ragazzi ho sentito una voce non sono
pazzo o amico che cazzo stai facendo
vuoi che ti faccio la scaletta così
passi sopra non lo so c'è c'è un tuo
amico qua ragazzi non so che cazzo vabbè
senti per favore di glielo tu che che
non è normale che continua a palpare le
transenne
vabbè io io vado avanti buongiorno anche
a lei
ragazzi non so che cosa sto che il cazzo
bbc sul paranormale pattumiera dunque
piscia tranquillo che non ti ho visto
nessuno poi lo tengo su facebook e il
loro vino
vabbè poi non ditelo esce zitti devo
andare avanti di qua prima che non è
perfetto c'è una discesa di qui ragazzi
dove no di nuovo nel giardino
maledizione non volevo ritornare nel
giardino [ __ ] c'è sono scelto
senza saperlo vabbé non importa
di nuovo sto pezzo di merda che cazzo è
questo ciò nasconde un nascondiglio hunt
obesi e il giardino come cazzo fai qua
c'è un altro nascondiglio devo dedurre
che l'obeso fa arrivare anche qui non
penso cioè non penso possa
effettivamente essere ovunque c'è che
cazzo è sennò che fai stato i ragazzi
devo trovare padre martin mio dio
con questo maniaco ragazzi sto
seriamente pensando che voglia mangiarmi
prima o poi non lo so guardato parati
come si scruta l'orizzonte è stronzo
cioè io non ho capito se cerca panini o
stesso no se sono io il panino non l'ho
capito c'è il mio dio questo qua mi
mangerà prima o poi sono sicuro
vabbè io devo devo trovare è arrivato di
qua perfetto io dico non ci vado a
prescindere vado entro qui dentro
qualsiasi posto è migliore di quello di
prima perché tanto di qua non ci passa
cerca padre martin nell'ala femminile
cosa ci fa parlare marty nella femminile
non lo voglio sapere
comunque sia ragazzi devo andare cos'è
cos'è
senta buon uomo sa perché ho visto padre
martino perché io non l'ho visto
entrerei ugualmente scusate il disturbo
anche per voi
entriamo perché se non idea di che cazzo
ci sto ancora fare qui dentro
prima eravamo nella maschile adesso
siamo nella la femminile ecco infatti
siamo dalla parte opposta cieli quelle
ancora la sedia a rotelle cioè mio dio
e vabbè comunque io non è da lì dove
cazzo sia padre martin
comunque va bene senti zio mi devi
spiegare come cazzo di fatto arrivare
lassù
hai visto il rider vero inizia a capire
ma non del tutto persino abramo ha
dovuto abbassare lo sguardo a terra ma
presto presto di qua la rivelazione che
attende dalla rivelazione ragazzi la
rivelazione raggiungi padre martin
passando per i piani superiori ragazzi
ma se padre martin ha preso lezioni da
altair per per riuscire a scalare ste
cose non è colpa mia
mio dio santissimo vabbè passiamo dico
anche se non so dove porta
ragazzi io mi sto preoccupando sempre
chi è quello identificati e così c'è
qualcosa che sta sbattendo senti non mi
prendere per il culo chiunque tu sia
non so dov'è finito padre martin non ne
ho la più pallida idea
c'è un tizio che sta passando da qualche
parte e inquietante da morire o comunque
noi andiamo avanti di qua per sicurezza
c'è un tizio di qua l'ho visto prima
non mi prendete per il culo permesso
ragazzi c'è qualcuno c'è un'altra sedia
a rotelle non è che se un altro dottore
maniaco no perché mi sono rimaste poche
dita po che non ci riuscirai di nuovo
vabbè
e io io vado parte grazie ragazzi sto
iniziando a preoccuparvi c'è una
batteria perfetto calma calma calma
senti io non ho brutte intenzioni
smettila di seguirmi stronzo le scale
sono di qua perfetto l'abbiamo ha girato
quel depravato mentale devo riuscire
assolutamente at non si apre per ragazzi
non arriverò mai al piano di sopra
questo è sicuro
siamo simili qua questa questa è
l'uscita di prima non è l'uscita di
prima quanti ascensori ci sono spiegate
melo non lo so troppo troppo gli
ascensori laga troppi ma ma questo non
era l'inizio
c'è questo mi pareva chi cazzo
buongiorno a tutti qualcuno che di
quella [ __ ]
ragazzi questo era tale quale ad est
cazzo vero che abbiamo imparato la
lezione mai fidarsi della gente che
fissa un muro cosa è quello una freccia
non c'è ragazzi le scale sono rotte
tutte caputa ra mio dio che salto
ragazzi sono un fenomeno padre martin
sarà alquanto atletico ma anche in fondo
me la cavo niente male ragazzi
nonostante non ci abbia due dita eco
tenete conto anche di questo ma andiamo
di qua perché tanto il 3 via non ci sono
perfetto scavalchiamo ormai non sono
anche più io dove sto andando ma ci
andiamo lo stesso i montacarichi nella
van der i ha bisogno di tre fusibili c'è
una chiave il fila due dita dentro e
predica ma non ce l'hai le dita giusto
scusami
vabbè non volevo offendere ti senti male
prendi turno perché io amico mio nono le
dita ti giuro lo farei io eh ma non ho
le dita e non posso vabbè se sei stronzo
è quando ti serve un favore non me lo
chiedere ragazzi devo trovare tre
fottuti fusibili batteria adesso che
sono pieno di batterie noi dobbiamo
capirci ma chi fa i cazzi tuoi ragazzi
non perché mi segue
cioè allora e attacca lui che sulla
sedia miur dio ragazzi c'è qualcuno ci
deve essere qualcuno che mi sai questo
non è contento
preferisco lui non so chi sia questo
prega per la rivelazione possiamo
pregare insieme e non voglio darti
fastidio cerco solo fusibili uno l'ho
trovato era tua lo sorgerà tuo calmo
herat un fusibile lo so che la tua
calmissimo calmissimo amico non volevano
balticus porca [ __ ] ragazzi e via di
qui preferivo a sto punto tizio di prima
che mi seguiva e stato bello ragazzi
dove il tizio di prima con quanta gente
mi serve quanta quanta togliti chiodi di
maledizione
c'è troppa gente ragazzi non ce la
faccio e passiamo di qua ragazzi perché
tanto non so drive in di nails vabbè se
lo dici tu
c'è qualcuno ha appeso ragazzi e non è
più un posto sicuro questo evidentemente
buongiorno io io allora e al tizio di
prima rubato il fusibile si è incazzato
spero che non lo faccio anche tu
bravo così tu mi piace di più vedere la
gente che mi sta simpatica si vede ad
occhio e driving nei so capital ora
facciamo un gioco che mi piace
moltissimo si chiama 123 cazzo no era
uno due tre stella non 1 e del 3 cazzo
però è va bene lo stesso fermo fermo
riordino di fermarti stronzo di merda ti
chiudo detto cazzo ragazzi non provate
mai a chiudere la gente che vi segue
nelle porte perché ci finite di mezzo
anche voi dico posso passare cc
maledetto ma che cazzo non sono anche
scavalcare una finestra di merda
perfetto non scavalchi tu vero invece si
ragazzi non so che cosa devo fare
abbiate pazienza
chiudi st parta toc toc tolo vedi questo
lo vedi bene e lo vedrai molto presto
c'era c'era il tizio cielo alti dove era
al tizio del muro prima non mi ricordo
più raga a perfetto invite the wall ride
è perfetto ma questa è l'ultima e
racconto fusi via per lo scivolo della
biancheria sarà un'impresa sorpassare il
tizio è infatti [ __ ] le batterie
adesso mi servono
e allora zio facciamo così non tornare
indietro che devo a girarti in qualche
modo vieni qua qua se è bravo così olio
cuore amico mio olio cuore devo riuscire
da qualche parte allora aspetta un
attimo seguin bravo bravo ragazzi c'è la
scrivania che devo girare perfetto ci
siamo ci siamo si chiama si chiama si
chiama ci prova stavolta ci provo lo
ritiene se grande ragazzi abbiamo fatto
in qualche modo ce l'ho fatta da occorre
la biancheria prima che quello stronzo
mi segua non ti alzare fermo fermo ok
devo governo non mi ricordo dove la
bianche fantastico siamo arrivati se ce
la possiamo fare
finché asti possibili hai bisogno della
i montacarichi l'avaria ha bisogno di
tre fucili ott refugiado metalli qualche
idiota di merda che sono ci siamo apriti
porca [ __ ] sì una chiave per una
chiave a [ __ ] mi devo buttare dentro
prima che il tizio arriva affanculo lami
botta cos'è successo
[Musica]
che cos'è cos'è
no no no non mi sono cadute le cuffie
sono le orecchie che fanno difetto
ragazzi cos'è porca [ __ ] smettila di
seguirmi e che cazzo fatti una vita dove
devo tornare praticamente la lavanderia
credo perché quella era della lavanderia
alla fine si se profondissimi di salti
mi servono sempre perché se no allora mi
pare che fosse lavanderia perfetto c'è
scritto qualora dobbiamo andare a destra
ancora ancora ma mio zio raga siete
tutti uguali fatevi una cazzo di vita
niente di tutto che hanno aspettato un
attimo che devo essere cortese nokia
va bè ragazzi dovrebbe essere qui se non
erro se vaffan ho girato il mondo per
arrivare qui da mista chiave la chiave
per accedere a piano 3 perfetto doveste
piano 3 cioè i ragazzi per la prima
volta un attuato una chiave che non so
che cosa apre perchè alla fine non ho
trovato nessun piano 3 se n'è andato
vedete che essere scortesi che la gente
ha un senso alla fine fino a un certo
punto ovviamente perché se no se
iniziano a correre come dei decerebrati
mentali siamo in un manicomio c'è un
motivo
ragazzi non so come cazzo aspettate che
fosse un'idea un'idea vieni qui melo
punto a tutto ragazzi già stoffa c'è sto
facendo delle cose incredibili
la cosa brutta che non so dove sto terzo
piano c'è poi anche piano noi è che
piano siamo adesso fatemi capire se
questo è il terzo piano questo qui no
non è il terzo piano ragazzi prima che
questi temi aggiunga [ __ ] devo
salire le scale di qua perfetto salita
leezza leezza leezza il veloce rocce si
ok prova a salire di qua e tu nun c'hai
la mia atletica stronzo e vorrei vederti
allora forse questo grazie a dio
allora ragazzi dobbiamo raggiungere sto
cazzo di padre martin ci dovremmo essere
finalmente dopo secoli vediamo se lo zio
fester non mi fa brutta sorpresa anche
lui perché ci manca solo questo file
audio blog seguì il sangue
segui la scia di sangue va bene ragazzi
dobbiamo seguire il sangue ovviamente
non potevamo seguire l'inchiostro una
penna
magari no il sangue va bene devo passare
devo fare slalom maniaco bisotto oppure
nel fantastico ragazzi se cado sono
cazzi miei
ma belli gli star calmo che ti arrivano
due schiaffi e devo saltare spettante
nati così si ok ho detto sì prima di
arrivare altra parte magari cadevo come
un deficiente ma non importa ciò che per
fece una freccia ragazzi il sax across
cazzo ragazzi son caduto di sotto bene
così ho fatto una stronzata dove sono
ragazzi quando andate in giro guardate
sempre a terra perché i casi sono due o
pestate una merda o cadete in zone che
non sapete neanche dove siete tipo io
adesso peccato sono caduto raga forse
riesco a fallire dai letti si mio dio
bene o male cioè pensavo di dovermi di
fare il giro non era così tragica la
cosa
fatemi soltanto capire dove sto buco che
non ho manco visto bene così ragazzi
avete la conferma che le troppo e ci
casco in pieno bene perfetto di qua e
non cazzo
[Musica]
padre cioè l'unico padre che si va a
nascondere amico via i peperoncini si
mangiano non si infilano nel culo però
vabbè è passato qualcuno che volava non
so come direi di andare da dove è
arrivato perché se no
buongiorno hai visto anche il tizio
passare mai mangiare peperoncini a
colazione amico mio babbo passiamo di
qua perché tanto non so dove andare
quindi tutte le strade sono uguali il
quale perfetto o senti ho sentito un
rumore se non ho capito cos'era comunque
noi andiamo avanti culo che cosa è
successo mi si è aperto steam va bene
così non si sa come gr grazie raga
grazie mi mancavate tantissimo si di
merda sentire la mancanza dei propri
amici col birillo di fuori è un qualcosa
che non apprezzo ragazzi è già già che
mi seguono tutti anche voi ci mancava te
c'è come cazzo che poi io vado avanti
sto gioco arrivando in aree
inaccessibili e non si sa come tizi che
ho incontrato all'inizio siano arrivati
fin qua sia lo penso che loro oggi hanno
il teletrasporto perché non lo so non me
lo spiego che chiude anche le porte so
stronzo c'è il mio dio mi ama ragazzi e
una gang bang
cioè io non so come fa a meno che non li
faccia a cascare nel buco magari ci
cascano pure lordo perso anno è perfetto
lì alla fase riescono a girarlo lo
stesso tipo così bravo grande ragazzi
solo fatta bene non era così difficile
va bene io avrei preferito farlo cadere
nel buco sinceramente ma va bene uguale
l'importante è che sigilli la porta una
volta che entrò perché non voglio
trovarmi nel deretano dato che ci hanno
birillo di fuori oggi
devo trovarmi lì dietro noi andiamo
avanti di qua padre martin spero credo
non si sia fatto ingrossare come si deve
da sti tizi perché non so dove un
ragazzino sotto sia del cazzo siamo
finiti
perché c'è ancora st molti ragazzi non
ce ne sono basta mettereste musica mi fa
cagare addosso
siamo ok perfetto padre martin era qui
all'inizio mi pare quindi dovremmo
essere nelle vicinanze comunque va bene
andiamo avanti qua perché tanto non so
da che parte andare io non credo che sia
passato di qua qualcuno però devo
saltare come un deficiente del barba
video campo la sfortuna videocamera ti
serve prendi la tua fredda avere ragazzi
concludo quindi episodio 6 video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato
argomento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come ogni video trovata una
descrizione se ne siete riusciti
iscrivetevi ci rivediamo il prossimo
vitobello ragazzi